from the post millennial we got big news
ladies and gentlemen late night shows go
dark his writer's Guild call strike well
I'm really excited for this because our
viewership should go up because clearly
the people who watch that show would
love to watch this show they're gonna
watch Freedom too I was around someone
this weekend who was like oh Tim Cass
that's on eight well now that I'm not
watching Tucker I'll watch Tim count yes
we're talking about Jimmy Kimmel and
Colbert what were Jimmy Kimmel's writers
they're sitting in the back room and
they're doing that thing that the vice
gag covering their eyes and then
grabbing
do you remember yeah yeah dude I mean I
gotta say when when I saw Stephen
Colbert do a song about vaccines and
make fun of people who don't like the
jab I was like he went there but he
wasn't there he wasn't making fun of
people who didn't like it he did it more
than it was just the vaccine and they
and it wasn't one thing conservatives
don't watch the show and they thought
Colbert did this one time thing where
everyone dressed up like syringes and
danced he did it every night he ever no
that's why I'm making fun of him saying
he's super lame no I'm saying I'm saying
it wasn't one time people I think it was
like this one thing they showed this one
Meme Over and Over I'm like dude he did
that every night every night he had the
vax scene where he was telling people to
get a medical treatment and it's like
it's the weirdest thing could you
imagine if if all of a sudden every
single lighthead house was like have you
tried flabestro and you're like why are
you telling me to take a drug and it's
like because we've all decided this
pharmaceutical just go to your doctor
don't go to Stephen Colbert to figure
out whether or not you need medicine go
to why is it that Joe Rogan gets ragged
on but Colbert gets a free pass
we showed the videos and we were like oh
they were completely different the man
looked like a Smurf in all of the
pictures and they're like we didn't edit
this yes that was cool he looked like he
looked like a normal man in the other
ones maybe a little second in this he's
blue
no this is it up to this it was
literally it was on that strike that
that top one that top left
different he looks like one of those
people who pretends to be a statue
in cities like on CNN that's what it
looked like on his actual Instagram does
this mean that Trump is not as orange as
people think he is
what the media
um saturation on Trump's picture
or orange that's a fact yeah you you
thought that was I never thought about
it really matter to me either way yeah
like maybe could pull that up too wait
you're telling me Trump is not really
orange well I mean Trump is go to his
rallies like if you've ever been to a
rally he does not look nearly as orange
as he does in all the pictures and
videos
I just like look at this look at here
here you go TV station editor sacked for
making Trump appear more orange no
no he's not really that orange though
that does make me sad that actually
really makes me kind of learning
something it was endearing I like that
about his tongue
[Laughter]
that tongue through they definitely the
neck looks wider did they make his mouth
wider yeah his lips are bulging
[Laughter]
he's known for like having like the
super dude but think about this they
actually did this on a TV show and so
there are regular people who are
watching who don't know and they think
that is Trump that's what they were
doing
but there was a uh there's a whole bunch
of pictures let me let me just Google
search it we don't there were a whole
bunch of pictures where they did this
that one made it look like he was
wearing Foundation he's got the fake the
fake tan for sure but this is what the
media would do they would boost
saturation to make it look like he's
more orange than he really is they would
do it all the time they do it to Tim too
they make me look less orange they're
like we can't let people know the
exactly what do you know his real power
level was it uh Isabel Isabella I love
being orange I always wondered that was
like you know that's her whole thing is
yeah it's like an Ode to Trump but now
we know we could tell her she's he's
fake you're actually more orange
Isabella I'm gonna send her this clip
afterwards and be like well you gotta
stop with the orange it has happened
more than once where there was something
with the lighting or the camera where I
was the only one on set who looked blue
and I have definitely gotten roasted by
the super chats for being blue and so
Tim basically did the same thing that
CNN did to Joe Rogan to me well but we
want that today like no I know so did
CNN
have Sheamus looking handsome you know
what I mean
you have to actually camera me out of
being handsome so yeah we have a filter
on James's face all the time that makes
him look the way he does otherwise I'm
actually normally really attractive but
I only look like this on camera that's
actually the most time that they spend
producing this is manipulating his face
so he's not so handsome exactly that and
writing her scripts that's what we spend
all our time doing well no we don't
write the scripts we read the scripts
some of you guys don't write the scripts
the scripts are handed down from very
important people that aren't supposed to
be named don't ask any more questions
about it man that's crazy what they did
to Joe Rogan yeah that's on CNN I know
it's not that crazy because we know how
they are but it is a little nuts they
tried making him look sickly like he had
like some kind of what melanoma it looks
like The Walking Dead he actually he
looks like a zombie course
and they tried when you first tried to
claim they didn't yeah they said they
didn't like no he just looks like that
and then people started coming out
saying like no no it's just different
monitor settings and I'm like dude I
screenshotted this video on the same
Monitor and it looked different like CNN
did some weird stuff CNN is the most
honest news source in America it seems
so petty it seems like if you were like
talking to middle school girls and she's
like I'm purposely gonna face tune this
girl so she looks worse than I do but
it's like this is the exact same thing
that they do with like these big
articles and these big news sources when
they do hit pieces is everyone sees the
original piece and their viewers
obviously aren't the highest IQ people
so they're like oh look at him he's
taking horsey worm where he looks like
crap but then they never see Joe Rogan's
statement after because he releases a
statement and they don't broadcast the
statement so it's like in their mind
that's just what he looks like yeah
I guess the good news is though they're
uh for the time being we get some
reprieve from the late night corporate
press garbage and I just love the fact
that even Bill Maher is off the air this
is a writer's strike yeah so what about
the political opinions of John Oliver
and Bill Maher are we not capable of
hearing because they don't have writers
that just shows interesting it's
everything I've been saying Bill Maher
does not read the news isn't it kind of
funny they're like well you know all the
most prominent uh left-wing thinkers are
going to be off the air for a little
while while why we ran out of clowns you
know yeah the Jokers decided to stop
writing the people who write their words
for them are striking so now they have
nothing to do but the comedian is right
this is the thing they don't make
anything funny
yeah no it's not funny and I'm not
saying none of them can be funny either
Colbert used to be funny he really did
he's just not he's not applying himself
I remember watching Colbert when I was a
kid and he was funny like I actually
enjoyed tuning in my parents would tune
in and we would laugh but now it's just
yeah I've heard people say that this
like format is pretty stale people don't
like it anymore they're all sitting
behind desk they all just opening
monologue it's all kind of the same
thing so it makes me wonder that like
with this writer Shrek will they ever be
able to recover any kind of viewership
hopefully I don't know what their
numbers are like right now but then also
what fills the vacuum like what takes
the place all they do all they do is
ever since Jon Stewart is they whittled
it down to saying something like Donald
Trump today came out did a backflip
that's kind of like a fat dog on
Christmas and then like named Timothy
and then it shows like a dog and then
everyone laughs it's like it's like
Saturday Night Live it's just right
evolved Photoshop like if a squirrel was
riding a jet ski and then they yeah
little Timothy over here cue the laugh
track
look at that score he really he loves it
and then he keeps leaning into the
Photoshop and is it doesn't mean that it
breaks down John Oliver's whole show and
it was like the whole thing is a single
formula it's an ad-lib where they would
take the same script and pull out proper
nouns and then put in different proper
nouns and it like doesn't miss a beat
wow and and to the point where he said
it's little Timothy like a whole bunch
of times little Timothy over here like
referencing a child and then saying it's
2016 people like it's current year why
is this happening but it was it's all
the same thing and they mentioned that
he'll pause the audience will laugh and
that was like reinforcing you must
believe this this is what everyone
agrees with laugh with this well
psychologically that's that's a whole
reason laugh tracks were created like
have you ever watched like I don't think
the Big Bang Theory is funny but a lot
of people love it so Big Bang Theory
they have Clips without the laugh tracks
you're just watching you're like none of
this it's disturbing funny at all well
laugh track cue is that psychological
aspect and oh yeah it's funny and
initially they did have live studio
audiences and I'm not sure if it was
this way from the get-go but eventually
even with those audiences they started
telling them you have to laugh right now
you're supposed to laugh at the joke
they have Jeb Bush they're going please
clap you know they were telling people
you have to find this funny
how do they get people for the audience
I wonder you know I know I know you have
to hire them too maybe that's what
really happened the audience went on
strike but I can't watch right I'm not
watching another vaccine you're making
my fears bleed I mean if you walk around
New York they'll come to you like hey
you want to watch a free comedy show and
you don't know what it is and then if
you walk you're like ah it's cold oh
it's cold there they got me I'm stuck
well can't leave you know I think they
lock the doors there's this weird thing
that happens where conservatives worship
any liberal who isn't as crazy as the
rest of the liberals so I want to make
it very clear I'm not engaging in that
when I say anything remotely positive
about Jon Stewart I think he's caused
many serious issues not a huge fan
however I will say that he was funny
compared to these guys he really was I
just I just figured it out what why
don't we just get like 500 moderate to
conservative types to go to the Jimmy
Kimmel audience and do it all Tim
because he's gonna be like so we got
this crazy video about Donald Trump and
then it's Trump being like we should
load Taxi
and then when he's like but Trump of
course is a is a criminal wait what your
booing means is Applause what would they
do when they would they cancel the show
and kick everybody out I've got a really
good idea it's like we'll do we'll
replace these late night shows we'll do
a late night show with me the live
studio audience will be the chickens
from chicken City and they'll balk and
clock and make all their various chicken
noises and that's how the audience will
know it's funny to touch on what you
said earlier about conservatives like
almost worshiping or like looking up to
the people that are more Lefty that
weren't as crazy they have this problem
with you know celebrities athletes we
have this problem all throughout the
industry as like when one person that
literally hates you and everything you
stand for they say one thing that you
kind of agree with you put them on a
pedestal for like a week and it's just
like trending Twitter clip after
trending Twitter clubs like they
literally hate you yeah
when Shia LaBeouf was doing
Catholic okay
I'm not gonna sit here and tell you
whether he was sincere or not that's up
that's not up to me but it was like all
the rage for a minute to be like we're
so happy he's one of us he's one of us
never mind anything else that's going on
or if he sticks with it oh he can't
repent I'm sure he could but did he I
hope so I mean Joe Biden says he's
Catholic too right yeah but here's the
thing Joe Biden explicitly does things
in public that tell us otherwise
and he openly defies Church teaching
children
should transition uh get over because I
think he was addicted to something for
quite a while and then he came through
that like all yeah like a bunch of
problems and then he went to rehab and
actually like put his life on a better
track and then that Catholic thing
happened from what I'm aware of yeah Joe
Biden said he was Catholic and his life
just went out of way worse draft I'm
Catholic his whole life support your
baby buddy yeah exactly I'm Catholic but
I don't believe in the Catholic Church
wait a minute that's called not being
Catholic thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time